[Music]
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now
or next our media group every difficult
decision was rooted in a long-term
strategy
for economic recovery tonight on
politics now the plan is working the
message from governor steve sisilak as
he lays out what he wants to do with an
unexpected 600 million dollars
the first lady visits las vegas for
stops at umc
and an honor for a local teacher plus
the biden administration wants to create
a public option for health care
i'm alexandra limon in washington with
the details of how that would work
coming up and facing execution concerns
of a lack of transparency from the state
about how they will execute zane floyd
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you very much for joining us i'm
john langler and we start with
good news for nevada's economy the
budget has nearly 600 million dollars
more than expected so that is money from
a combination of extra tax revenue
and federal money from congressional
stimulus bills lawmakers here in nevada
now have 586 million dollars
more than the prediction from the
economic forum in december
the state budget was built off of that
december prediction
so what is nevada going to do with that
extra money well governor steve sisolak
says the state needs to reinvest in
itself
just like you and your family might we
need to take the same approach
we need to refill our savings account
pay off our debts
and restore the difficult cuts that we
suffered in areas like mental health
and education we need to bring our state
back to a baseline
and we also need to fix what's broken by
investing in new systems
including the one at dieter the governor
appraised the belt tightening done over
the last year to deal with the budget
shortfall
you'll remember lawmakers drained
nevada's rainy day fund and cut some
essential services early in the pandemic
about 350 000 nevadans don't have health
insurance
and we also rank near the bottom on
health care affordability
and those are two reasons senate
majority leader nicole cannazzaro is
trying to create a public option for
health insurance
senate bill 420 had its first hearing
this week it requires insurance
companies that offer coverage to
nevadans on medicaid to also offer a
public option
those plans would also be marked down
five percent with the goal of that
markdown being 15 percent in four years
canazarro says now is the perfect time
to take advantage of the state's
bargaining power to lower costs
republican state senator ben kikefer
asked about the cost to hospitals
just because we say that a health
insurance plan needs to have premiums
that are 15 percent less that doesn't
reduce
costs by 15 right um it may
may actually increase costs and increase
utilization and
there are a lot of different factors
that could happen downstream
who's going to pick up that cost i pose
a question that
it is more expensive to cover
individuals who come in for
more acute conditions through the
utilization of
emergency services more often than not
or where a condition has gone untreated
for a significant period of time
and therefore the treatment and
mitigation of whatever that disease is
is far more expensive and far more
intrusive and and difficult to deal with
the bill would also increase coverage
options for pregnant women
that cost was estimated to be 75 million
dollars this biennium
and 100 million dollars the one after
that the silver state health exchange
estimated another 10 million
dollars most of that is because of
medicaid changes if approved the public
option would start in 2026
first lady dr jill biden was in las
vegas this week and
shortly after surprising the teacher of
the year which we'll cover later
she thanked valley nurses and stopped by
umc to show her appreciation jomola was
there
it was a big day for us from smiles to
tears surprise
excitement there was a mix of emotions
at umc thursday
she said she thanked me and yeah it was
wonderful the first lady jill biden made
sure to thank health care workers
amy runge has been a nurse for 24 years
and this past year she says has been the
most difficult
it was exhausting it was tiring it was
part of history a managing nurse now
ranji is thankful dr biden is shedding
light on the work being done
that washington our president our first
lady supports nevada
supports nursing supports umc hospital
is huge i'm proud
nurses even walked away with a unique
white house baked cookie
i don't know if i even want to eat
because it's so pretty i may just freeze
and save
the ceo of umc mason ben howling knows
it has been a long year for these health
care workers
really focusing on their mental health
their social health and just trying to
keep morale up and with the first lady's
visit that certainly helps
with that morale boost joe mohler
8 news now and as i mentioned a little
later in the program we'll tell you
about nevada's first
national teacher of the year who the
first lady surprised thursday morning
the next big goal for the bide
administration is passing the
president's infrastructure plan
one part of the plan deals with
everything from health care to education
it's called the american family's plan
secretary of health and human services
javier bacara
says it would provide coverage similar
to medicare
senate republican leader mitch mcconnell
says the plan's two trillion dollar
price tag is far too expensive
unmask the unfairness
of some families who have to work
to be able to pay the rent or the
mortgage fee the family
yet can't go to work because their
children were not able to go to school
our colleagues on the other side of the
aisle just can't resist
stretching out the pandemic using it as
a rationale
for additional spending far beyond what
is best
for the country joining us now to talk
about this is alex limon from our
washington dc bureau
president biden's infrastructure plan
has two parts there is the traditional
infrastructure for things like
transportation
but let's talk about the second part and
the highlights of the american family's
plan
president biden is billing this american
family's plan
as the second half of his infrastructure
proposal and what the
administration says is that this plan
invests in
human infrastructure and the reason is
that the bulk of the
plan focuses on investing in things like
education
and health care so for example the
administration is proposing
free universal preschool for all three
and four-year-olds
three and four-year-olds as well as free
community college for two years
and that would include free community
college for dreamers for example
the administration says it also wants to
invest billions and billions of dollars
in child care saying that low and middle
income families for example
shouldn't have to pay more than seven
percent of their income toward
child care and then another highlight of
the healthcare aspect of this
is that they want to provide paid family
medical leave to
all families i'm making that available
when they need it
as well as a public option for
healthcare insurance this is something
that progressives you know have talked a
lot about and that the administration is
now saying they want to make
a reality and i spoke to the secretary
of health and human services
about how that public option would work
and he says the idea here is that it
would be
available nationally so that it creates
competition
amongst health insurance companies to
ensure that americans are getting
the best health insurance at the best
prices so
some competition would be injected into
that field essentially
republicans have expressed opposition to
the first part of the infrastructure
package which was about two trillion
dollars
what's been the response from the gop on
capitol hill to the second part
well they hate the second part even more
and it also comes in at a cost
of about two trillion dollars so all
together you're talking about
close to four trillion dollars in costs
in addition to that republicans say this
second part of the plan they don't
consider it to even be
infrastructure or infrastructure related
so they don't think it should be part of
an
infrastructure proposal senator mitch
mcconnell this week also said
he accused democrats of being unable to
let go
of the pandemic saying they continue to
use it
as an excuse for essentially endless
spending
when when it doesn't need to happen
according to mcconnell
and again that was alex simone from
washington d.c
the state of nevada is planning to
execute zane
floyd however his lawyers and even a
federal judge are questioning
a lack of transparency from the state
the i-team's vanessa murphy was in a
federal court hearing this week and
tells us what unfolded
this used to be albertsons and this is
where zane floyd
walked inside and killed four employees
and
injured another in 1999
now more than 20 years later the state
of nevada
is trying to execute him there's
not a whole lot i can
say to the families that was zane floyd
more than 20 years ago
now while nevada lawmakers are
considering abolishing the death penalty
the state is trying to move forward with
plans to
execute floyd it's not yet final but a
date could be set for early june
the nevada department of corrections or
ndoc has released
no details a spokeswoman tells the
i-team
information will be released no less
than seven days before the execution
date
floyd's defense team points out floyd
has a right to know which drugs will be
used to kill him
and lawyers need time to review the plan
the nevada attorney general's office
which
represents endac argues if the names of
the drugs are released
drug companies may sue to make sure
their drugs aren't used
for lethal injection that's what
happened in the case against
scott dozier the last inmate nevada
tried to execute
federal judge richard boulware even
questioned the lack of transparency
thursday
and wants lawyers back in court monday
the head of endoc testified but revealed
no
information about the plan director
charles daniels said he takes his duty
to carry out the execution seriously
and pointed out quote there is no do
over button
end quote i can't take back what i've
done
if there was any way i could i would and
judge bulware asked
several questions about why there is so
much secrecy about the plan to execute
floyd
we are potentially four weeks away from
nevada's first
execution in about 15 years with no
information released vanessa murphy 8
news now
meanwhile a bill that would abolish the
death penalty here in nevada has already
passed the state assembly it had its
first hearing in the state
senate as well however governor sisalek
says he does not support a full
abolition of executions
next on politics now a plan to build a
smart city
where we had a real problem was the
separatist
local government up next we speak with
story county about the governor's plan
to create a semi-autonomous government
for one company up
in northern nevada and we take a look at
how much money the governor has stashed
away for a re-election run in 2022
welcome back to politics now
so we've been telling you about the
ambitious plan to allow businesses in
rural
northern nevada to create their own mini
governments called innovation zones
so that is now a study but first let's
show you what we're talking about first
it's up here in northern nevada
up in story county where they plan to
build a smart city
on 67 000 acres of undeveloped land this
is in the tahoe regional industrial
center
uh the tesla gigafactory is right there
as well also the part of this innovation
zone they wish to create
now the plan was pitched by blockchain
llc blockchain said that local
governments were simply inadequate to
properly deal with their innovative
technologies
so they wanted to create their own
semi-autonomous local government within
story county
well i spoke with story county manager
austin austin osborne
about how it all went down the plan was
not to involve story counting
at least the way the draft it was
drafted the way it was discussed
what frustration was there from the
story county's point of view on the way
things were going
the frustration some of it is even to
this day we were never provided
uh what the bill draft review was to
look like
so the best thing we could do as a team
is to work on
what we did have which was some document
that was provided us
in march that was to resemble a bill
draft but we weren't sure exactly you
know if that was going to you know be
what was to be dropped
in the legislature or not where we had a
real problem
was the separatist local government
the idea that for some reason that you
know a county or story county can't keep
up with them you know to move any faster
so that they have to separate into a
completely other government
we opposed very strongly and we met with
legislators and we met with regional
leaders
and talked them about that position and
we met with the group
the proponents as well and said you want
to do
almost all of the things you want to do
technology growth
a residential growth at a try submit an
application
get a 30-day grading permit get a or a
5-day grading permit get a 30-day
building permit
go through the plan unit development
process we'll get you up and running
but don't separate from local government
the separating
uh would be detrimental to story county
what
okay fine they want to do their own
thing why should story county
uh be a part of the process
well you know there's different parts to
it but one is
they want to separate into a separate
local county
but we would continue providing the
services to that county
uh fire sheriff assessor's office
building department how is that going to
work
what happens if we have the building
department it just doesn't work
you know and then as they grow over time
they want to start taking away
certain services that they don't want us
to provide anymore
you could get into a situation where uh
there is one group of you know building
inspectors inspecting buildings that
don't have any control
from us but then it's our fire
department folks that have to go in and
respond to that life safety emergency or
a fire
you know that's one issue another issue
with revenues
we have strategically zoned property
threat or
county to make sure that when we see
residential and other growth occur
in the next 20 30 50 years that we have
enough tax base in order to cover the
services that will be required to do
that
this proposal takes away a third of the
county
including a lot of the industrial and
commercial zone properties
potentially could lead to other
annexations in the future the bill draft
that we were provided
did not address those and we're
concerned about that
are you glad with how this ended up
concluding uh at this point you know i
think the best answer to that is
you know like i said at the beginning of
this you know we would like to see
innovative technology happen in our
county whether it's
technology out a tri center a smart city
out there at painted rock you know that
sort of thing
so i look and say you know there's still
opportunity for good things to happen in
the county
just not in the way it was being
presented
the saga continues on thursday governor
steve siselek introduced senate
concurrent resolution 11. so that'll
create a joint special committee
to analyze this innovation own proposal
for the future
that committee would then submit a
report before the end of the year
and come up with a new bill draft moving
forward
this week in following the money we want
to take a look at the potential
2022 governor's race current governor
steve sislak has built a pretty big war
chest already
with more than four and a half million
dollars already
for the end of 2021. he raised a record
11.3 million dollars
in the 2018 campaign and you can see
that number there he raised a lot of
money when he first became governor
now meanwhile the republican challengers
potential ones anyway that list is
taking shape the list includes
congressman mark amade clark county
sheriff joe lombardo
former lieutenant governor mark
hutchison and north las vegas mayor john
lee
that will sort itself out in the very
near future
next on politics now back on facebook
deciding whether former president trump
can go back on that social media
platform
and the national teacher of the year is
from right here in clark county we'll
introduce you to her next
you're watching politics now
former president donald trump may get
his facebook page back we're just
not really sure when this week
facebook's independent oversight board
weighed in on his indefinite permanent
suspension
mr trump was kicked off after the
january 6 capitol hill riot
the board said this week it was not
appropriate for facebook to impose the
indeterminate
and standardless penalty of an
indefinite suspension
it told facebook to review the matter
within six months
there are actually clear rules within
facebook themselves in their community
standards
to which penalties and sanctions they
can use but in this case they chose
not to use any of these but use an
indefinite penalty and they can't do
that
the board agreed the former president
violated facebook's rules prohibiting
praise or support of people engaged in
violence
in a statement mr trump called what the
social media companies have done quote a
total disgrace
but he will stay blocked for six more
months and then a final decision is
expected
the number of registered partisan voters
in nevada continues to drop
in april active registered democrats
decrease as you see there by about 1
180. active republicans decreased by
about 2 300
nonpartisans increased in nevada by 8
000 voters
this week democratic senator jackie
rosen was back here in nevada and toured
some strip
properties the senator met with staff
over at new york new york and t-mobile
arena
rosen back in las vegas after chairing
the first subcommittee meeting on
tourism
as part of the american rescue plan
states like nevada received millions of
dollars in federal funding to offset job
losses
and help try and boost the travel
industry
next on politics now the teacher of the
year in our own backyard
booker elementary school teacher juliana
ortube was crowned 2021's national
teacher of the year and she's from
right here in nevada up in las vegas
kirsten joyce shows us her surprise
first lady and english teacher dr jill
biden traveled here to las vegas to
surprise this year's national teacher of
the year
juliana erda bay live on cbs this
morning
look at juliana i mean she is just the
epitome
of a great teacher a great educator
erda bay is a special education teacher
at kermit booker elementary school
teaching is hard to work you know it's a
work of the heart and
it's about connecting and making
relationships one of the things that i
love the most is i love learning in the
garden
affectionately called miss earth she's
used a garden as her classroom and has
raised funds for garden programs at two
schools
it was a bit like a dream there's some
butterflies around in
ladybugs i think it just changed my life
she's known for going above and beyond
meeting her students differing academic
social and behavioral needs
many of whom are english language
learners i would describe mr debay
as kind-hearted
fun conditional she just wants to say
thank you for everything
taking care of all the kids and just
looking out for everybody
it's been a challenging year for
teachers helping students navigate
learning in a pandemic
hopefully you know all of america after
this pandemic has seen what
teachers have done who taught you that
ertabay will spend the next year serving
as an ambassador for education and
advocate for all
teachers each school is unique and they
have their own special set of needs and
so that's why i'm advocating for a
joyous and just education
a mission she's already made her life's
work kirsten joyce
8 news now and governor sislak also
declared may 6th a day in honor of
ertube congratulations to her
in this week's what to watch some key
dates for the state legislature
may 14th is the deadline for bills to
pass out of their committee in the
second house
the next day is the deadline to finish
resolving all of the budgets for state
agencies
now that we have the new economic
projections the
session is scheduled to wrap up in
carson city on may 31st
and with that we thank you very much for
watching politics now we'll see you
again next week
take care
[Music]
you